FRED SAUER: What's the best
strategy to respond to
requests that probably
take more than
60 seconds to process?
MANDY WAITE: Was that part
of the question?
So make it back in process.
It's a process to request.
That's the best thing to do.
You can do these things out of
bound almost from the actual
request itself.
So if the user makes a request,
you need to actually
service that request within 60
seconds otherwise you'll hit a
deadline exceeded exception
in both for
Java and Python runtimes.
That's a request timeout that we
have that's always in place
for what we call frontend
instances currently.
There's no such limitation
on backend instances.
So what Fred said about moving
to the server model, if you
choose to use a standard
instance that's not using
autoscale, those things
won't apply.
It won't automatically hit
its request timeout.
So the best thing to do is if
you need to do heavy lifting,
then when working to answer a
user request, you should find
a way to do that asynchronously
out of bound
from actually responding
to the user.
So long-running task, let's say
the user makes a request
or is always generating 100
emails to different people.
What you need to do is return
the request back, which bumps
out the user pretty quickly.
And offline do them in the
background of the email-- the
email processing using
a backend instance.
It doesn't need to be
You can push it off to task
queues and then you can start
using things like Compute Engine
and such like too.
Compute Engine has the
ability to do pull
requests using task queues.
So you can use Compute Engine
instances to service those
requests as well.
But yeah, basically take it
away from the frontend
instances and push it into the
background somewhere using the
backend process or
Compute Engine.
FRED SAUER: Yep, task queue is
definitely the way to go.
The pull queues you mentioned
are great for working with
external systems like doing
off App Engine work, like
Compute Engine, but you could
really do it on a server that
you have sitting on a rack in
your office if you have some
special processing that
you need to do.
And then push queues are a great
way of enqueuing work
asynchronously.
And those requests come back to
your application as if it
were traffic, but it's
internal traffic.
So App Engine will scale up and
down if you create more
requests and then you have a 10
minute deadline instead of
a 60 second, so you can easily
make those long-running URL
Fetch calls or do more
complex processing.